sometimes seeing the trailers for
upcoming features can be the best part
of going to the theater but as we all
know the final product can be very
different from the way it's portrayed in
the promo clips in fact sometimes
trailers flat-out lie to us here are
some of the worst offenders snow dogs it
sure looks like it has all the hallmarks
of a classic live-action talking animal
movie it's made by Disney shares a
producer with Georgia the jungle and
Charlotte's Web and the trailer even
ends with a clip of wisecracking dogs
but viewers expecting 2002's snow dogs
to be a raucous fish-out-of-water story
with funny canines and copious pratfalls
were given well pretty much that only
without any talking animals anyone
expecting Air Bud went home disappointed
as the scene where the dogs mock Cuba
Gooding jr. 'he's character is actually
from a dream sequence kangaroo jack the
blatantly misleading trailer for snow
dogs was a direct inspiration for
kangaroo Jack's infamously misleading
marketing according to the Los Angeles
Times inspired by the earlier film
producer Jerry Bruckheimer made Jack
look less like a dark mafia comedy and
more like a light family-friendly romp
focused on kangaroo related hijinks I
said they did walk like snow dogs the
talking animal scene is just a dream but
the trailer doesn't make that clear a
rapping kangaroo combined with repeated
shots of the lead characters screaming
and Pratt falling help to convince
parents that the movie was goofy
family-friendly fair instead thousands
of kids found some surprisingly lewd
humor and a baffling plot about adult
friendships and failed dreams Sweeney
Todd the Demon Barber of Fleet Street
yes it's been a musical on Broadway for
decades but the trailer for Tim Burton
Sweeney Todd the Demon Barber of Fleet
Street does everything it can to hide
that fact a clip of Johnny Depp Hawk
singing is buried within a preview that
makes the gothic musical look more like
a combination of Dexter The Count of
Monte Cristo and an action thriller why
the trailer does everything it can to
hide its
musical roots is anyone's guess
especially when it looks identical to
every other Tim Burton movie without it
observe and report an unrelenting
in-depth examination of a profoundly
disturbed individual 2009's observe and
report is like taxi driver filtered
through the madcap antics of Seth
Rogen's everyman comedy stylings but
you'd be hard-pressed to tell by
watching the trailer which makes it look
like a stealth sequel to paul blart mall
cop or at least i rated our parody of it
the clip looks like it's advertising yet
another story of a schlubby guy and a
crummy job finding worth and acceptance
and proving himself a hero but the
actual plot of the movie is closer to
the drug-filled last days of a genuine
psychopath godzilla 2014 was a mourning
period for fans of Walter White's
misadventures on the popular TV show
Breaking Bad it had been off the air for
a year by that point and fans were
missing Bryan Cranston's nuanced
portrayal of a beleaguered family man
making huge sacrifices for the ones he
loves
but then the trailer for Godzilla
arrived showing Cranston once again as a
beleaguered family man this time
struggling to stop the famous monster
unfortunately the trailer was clearly
cut once the marketing team realized how
popular Cranston had become he's only in
the movie for just more than one quarter
of the runtime a major bait and switch
ravenous going by the trailer 1999's
ravenous looks like a screwball comedy
or a Troma film that was stuck in the
vault for twenty years what audiences
missed out on was an audacious horror
comedy with a remarkable performance by
Guy Pearce the movies take on
cannibalism deserves to go down as a
formative horror text but it's hard to
convince anyone to watch after they've
seen the trailer on the bright side
unlike many of the other movies on this
list the only life this trailer is
telling is that the movie isn't
fantastic drive director Nicolas
reference drive is a slow thorough
examination of crime and career
criminals wrapped in layers of allegory
and striking cinematography which is why
it's so ridiculous that the trailer
makes it look like a Fast and the
Furious flick all pulse-pounding chase
sequences and fight scenes the marketing
was so misleading that one woman
even sued the distributor complaining
that the movie had very little driving
all that's missing has been diesel
shouting about family who's always room
for family thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our youtube
channel let's check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]